hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so
today we're gonna solve lowest common
ancestor of a binary search tree
and if you recall a while ago in a video
i showed you guys this
sheet of the 75 blind problems that have
become pretty popular and so this is
basically a spreadsheet that i showed
with an entire list of those problems
and i've actually ended up making videos
for most of these problems so far
the video that we're doing today is
actually going to be lowest common
ancestor one of the few problems that i
haven't done yet so
i will be linking this sheet in the
description if you do want to take a
look and i'll probably be trying to wrap
up most of the problems in this list i
think one of the
next ones that i'm going to be doing is
alien dictionary because i really like
that problem
and once i've gotten this entire sheet
of problems done i'll probably be making
a playlist for it
but for now you can watch the videos
that are currently available for this
list of problems
so in this problem we're given a binary
search tree and we're and we're supposed
to find the lowest common ancestor of
two
given input nodes in the binary search
tree
and so the lowest common ancestor is
basically defined as being the lowest
node in the tree such that p
and q are descendants of this
node or p or q happens to be equal to
this node
so basically what we're saying is six
can technically be a descendant of
itself
so for example in this problem in this
example we're given p equals two q
equals eight so we're going to start at
the root
because the root is always going to be a
common ancestor of
every single node in the tree right
that's just
kind of basic right for you know this
node in this node of course
this is going to be a common ancestor
it's not necessarily the lowest common
ancestor
but it is a common ancestor so
what we're gonna see is p is less than
six therefore it's going to be in the
left subtree and it actually happens to
be a direct
child of six eight happens to be greater
than six so it's gonna go in the right
subtree
so basically if we went in the left sub
tree two is two
going to be a ancestor of
two and eight of course not right two
can't be an ancestor of the node eight
if it's in a different subtree
similarly eight is not going to be a
common ancestor of two
so basically if we look at this level or
if we keep going down
we're never gonna find a common ancestor
between two and eight so the lowest one
that we found
ended up being six so we notice if
there's a split
between the nodes that p and q
are going at if they're going in
separate sub trees where that split
occurs is going to be the lowest common
ancestor
so if i change this problem slightly and
i gave
p as 7 and q as 9 we would once again
start at the root because we know this
is going to be a common ancestor of
these two nodes
and so now we're going to check okay 7
is greater
than 6 right and 9 is
also greater than 6. so therefore we
don't need to search in separate
subtrees we can just go to the right
subtree to look for both of these values
we know that this is not going to be the
lowest common ancestor this could
potentially though
be the lowest common ancestor so now
once again we're going to repeat that
we're going to say 7
that's going to be less than eight so
for a seven we're gonna have to look in
the left subtree
nine is greater than eight so for that
we're gonna have to look in the right
subtree so
since this is where the split occurred
that means this is going to be the
lowest common ancestor for this
input so we would return this node as
the lowest common ancestor
so one last case is if we changed q
to be a six so once again we would start
at the root right before we were
checking if p
and q were both greater than six then we
look in the right subtree
if they're both less than six then we
look in the left sub tree
if they're if one of them is in the
right sub tree and one of them is
in the left sub tree that's how we know
this is the lowest common ancestor but
what about the last edge case
where one of these nodes happens to be
equal to the root node
in that case this is potentially the
lowest common ancestor
it's definitely a common ancestor of
both of these but now if we go
lower for sure none of the descendants
of this
node nothing in the left subtree or in
the right subtree is going to be a
ancestor of this node itself right so
basically
if we ever reach the node itself for
example six
then that's going to be the lowest
common ancestor so it's
an ancestor of itself and it's also an
ancestor of
seven which can be found down here right
so this problem isn't too difficult once
you can kind of understand that if
there's
a split between these two nodes then
that's going to be the lca the
lowest common ancestor and since we're
doing it this way we don't have to visit
every single node in the entire tree so
the time complexity is not going to be
big o of n it's going to be
log n because we're only going to have
to visit one
node for every single level in the tree
so basically the time complexity is the
height of the tree which is usually
going to be log n
and the memory complexity is just going
to be big o of 1 because we're not
really needing any data structures or
anything like
that that being said let's jump into the
code now so as i mentioned we are going
to start
ourselves at the root node and we're
basically going to continue until we
find our result
so we're guaranteed to find a result p
and q are guaranteed to exist
in the input tree so what we're just
going to say is while current is not
null now it's never going to be null
because we are going to find a result
but this is just a way to get it to
execute forever until we find that
result
so one case would be if the p-value and
the q
value were both greater than the root
value or the current value that we're
visiting
and in that case we would have to go
down the right subtree
so since we're going down the right
subtree we can update our current
pointer to current dot
right now the else case is basically
going to be the opposite of this
so i'm just going to copy and paste that
basically if both of the values happen
to be
less than the current node that we're
visiting in that case we would want to
go down the left subtree
so in that case we can update current
and set it equal to current dot
left now the last case is basically if
our split occurs or if we end up
actually
finding basically finding one of the
values p or
q and in that case it basically means we
have found our result either way so we
would just be able to return
current itself now we don't have to put
any return statement outside of the loop
because we're guaranteed that this is
going to execute at some point
so as you can see this is a pretty
efficient solution
so i hope that this was helpful if it
was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel a lot and i'll
hopefully
see you pretty soon thanks for watching